– Hey!
– Nico! Was machst du hier?
– Ich bin hier, weil ich dich sehen will.
– Wie war dein Termin bei der
Agentur für Arbeit?
– Sehr gut. Ich werde
eine Ausbildung zum –
wie ist das Wort? –
Zweiradmechatroniker machen.
Ich werde eine Ausbildung zum
– Was ist das?
– Ich arbeite in einer Werkstatt und muss
da Fahrräder und Motorräder reparieren.
– Also alles mit zwei Rädern?
– Ja. Die Ausbildung dauert drei Jahre.
– Das klingt super.
– Ja. Find ich auch, denn
ich muss endlich Geld verdienen.
– Geht das?
– Zuerst muss ich eine
Sprachprüfung bestehen
und dann kann ich
die Ausbildung beginnen.
– Das schaffst du, Nico.
Jetzt sei doch mal optimistisch!
So schwer ist die Prüfung auch nicht.
Du musst dich gut darauf vorbereiten.
– Ja, ich weiß. Und was ist mit dir?
– Ich möchte studieren, aber ich weiß
noch nicht so genau, was.
Es gibt so viele Studienfächer!
Aber im Moment brauch
ich vor allen Dingen einen Job.
– Und suchst du schon?
– Ich kann schlecht einen Job suchen,
wenn ich immer zu Hause bleiben muss.
– Es geht um deine Zukunft!
– Komisch. Das sagen
meine Eltern auch immer.
Ich muss wieder nach oben.
– Bis bald!